we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here is a caller who
is telling me I'm wrong Donald Trump
didn't get arrested now you might be
saying David when did you say Trump got
arrested and of course the answer is
never listen to the confusion here
hey David it's Frank from Florida yeah
I'm watching your segment on uh
wondering if Trump uh got arrested yeah
there's no way in the world that that
happened okay and him being quiet about
it okay he'd be screaming holy hell
um so I doubt very much that's what
happened yeah I never said that Trump
got arrested so the story Monday was
Trump's suddenly in DC
unannounced trip he's just there and
there's speculation as to why
is he in DC because he's going to get
arrested he's been told you have to turn
yourself in
is he in DC because he is just playing
golf so I never said maybe Trump got
arrested and nobody heard about it of
course if Trump had gotten arrested we
would have heard about it the
speculation was has he come to DC
because he has been told by law
enforcement he has to surrender and
that's not what it was but
it wasn't the claim that I made so I'm
glad to get the opportunity to clarify
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today it's it really speaking of Alex
Jones this is a bonus show that's going
to throw him off his rocker oh the bonus
show where you want to make money and
everybody else makes money to find
themselves as bad this one's really
going to send him for a loop Ken Starr
the prosecutor of the Clinton Whitewater
investigation has died at age 76. this
is one of the earliest political
memories I have the the this
investigation done by Ken Starr we're
going to talk about it on the bonus show
Alabama may start using nitrogen hypoxia
for executions for a death sentence
executions for people on death row what
is it and does this present new legal
problems as Alabama has been plagued by
issues when it comes to executions and
we are going to talk about the broader
based inflation that we have been seeing
recently uh where is it what sectors and
what are the implications all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
you can get instant access by signing up
at joinpakman.com we are also now only
five days away from our one day blowout
membership special Monday morning 9 19.
we are doing a 9 19 themed membership
discount
to try to do a record one day membership
Drive bigger than we've ever done before
let's hope if you want to be notified
Hey sir or ma'am here's the coupon code
take advantage of it you need only sign
up for my newsletter at davidpackman.com
and then Monday 9 19.
you will get that beautiful and clear
email with instructions on how to do it
so for our current members we will see
you on the bonus show for our future
members look forward to welcoming you on
Monday